juste se lever le matin se faire un
fantastique a fait regarder le ciel les
oiseaux année aux sports parler aux gens
qu'on aime ne pas se soucier des
jalouses à et des clochards great
énergie enron open doors voilà mon
advise pour être le king et la queen
much of afida turner en direct de mon
salon et me paraît
anormal vote blanc votes nuls quelques
différences salut moi c'est votre blanc
et moi ces votes nuls enchanté moi mon
grand truc c'est les enveloppes vides
quand un électeur choisi de ne pas
choisir et qu'il exprime clairement dans
l'isoloir ah ouais moi je suis plutôt
bulletins déchirés ou à noter que ce
soit volontaire ou non d'ailleurs un on
a quand même un petit point commun tous
les deux toi comme moi on est
comptabilisée ouais d'accord on est
comptabilisé mais toi comme moi on n'a
aucun impact sur le résultat du vote on
devrait peut-être en était l'abstention
notre apéro non
abysses
[Rires]
il faut que tu dises le tuyau de douche
du bon du tout si mes gars prennent pas
canada
propos des cales
asie beaucoup d k way comme salade ou
comme saga doute
un bon état
bonjour s'il vous plaît argent
c'est
encore 4 millions de 999
1000mercis
mars et argent s'il vous plaît 5
millions juste 5 millions s'il vous
plaît s'il vous plaît
elle est parfaite on la garde non mais
on va où là et non mais 5 millions alors
je sais pas combien de 2 millions de
bâtiments à elle et à lever 5 millions
bon nous on va le donner je suis sûr
qu'à delhi il ya des gens qui vont
donner pas dit donnez donnez donnez
donnez
donnez lui donnez donnez donnez donnez
lui de l'argent 5 millions allez ciao
est parfaite on la garde